- Okay, so I had kind of a
crazy afternoon the other day.
My producing partner, Amber,
25 years we've been together.
She's right over there.
(audience clapping)
Go Amber!
So we helped out a dog,
that had been involved in a hit and run.
And what happened was, okay,
so our friend Prika starts
crying and screaming
and we're like, what's going on?
And so he tells us that he just
saw a dog get hit by a car.
So Amber and I ran across
the street to help.
And it was just a very jarring experience
but it was an amazing reminder
of how sometimes strangers
can come together for help.
There was a bunch of us
crowded around the dog
and then eventually I
got the dog on the leash
and stayed with it.
And then I was like scared to touch it,
'cause I wanted to pet the head,
and I was like, you've
just been in an accident.
And it was just a wild experience.
But I tried to give calm
and good energy to the dog.
And everyone was just
trying to do their best.
And look, even a paparazzi
pitched in and took photos.
This is a community experience.
And then we put the dog in Amber's car
and took it to the vet
and I'm happy to tell you,
that the dog is going to be okay.
(audience cheering)
(cheers) All right, our
VFS, you guys look amazing!
I'm calling for a Colleen
and Steve, are you there?
- Hi, hello!
- Oh!
- [Colleen] Hi!
- Hi guys!
- We love you, we love "Drew's News",
we love the intro, we love your show.
- You guys do, I'm so thrilled!
(audience clapping)
The whole news crew and I,
Eric and Sammy, the whole team,
we love sound effects,
we have a cat screeching
in there and everything.
So thank you and can you know what?
- [Colleen] You're welcome.
- In honor of you guys, I'm
gonna kick off "Drew's News"
and dedicate it to you today!
(audience cheering)
Let's do it, it's time for "Drew's News!"
(loud crash)
(cat yelps)
(dramatic music)
Sir, ma'am, guy!
Ma'am, I asked you a question!
It's "Drew's News!"
All right, let's see what made the papers!
Okay so, this is kind of a weird story.
You know, the show, "The Masked Singer?"
It's so fun.
Apparently, people on the internet
are convinced I'm the popcorn.
Guys, I'm totally not
the popcorn, I promise.
However, I am legally
forbidden from commenting
on whether or not I am the crocodile.
And I'm also not saying anything
about that sun, so stop asking.
Ahem, up next, when I read
this story with the news crew,
I thought, yeah, this all tracks.
Check this out, The Wall
Street Journal yesterday asked,
is the bra dead?
They're reporting that
bra purchases are down.
And I feel for the bra companies,
I certainly don't want
them to be in any trouble.
But people are working from home
and they're going more
loosey goosey, you know?
I can only speak for myself on this one.
I don't think there's anything
more medieval than the bra.
I hate it, kill it, live
that loosey goosey life.
#livelooseygoosey.
(audience clapping)
Moving on, if you ever thought, aw man!
I wish there was a candy
that tasted like meat.
(audience chuckling)
Well, get ready for
this, it's "Food News!"
- [Woman] Nom nom nom.
- (chuckles) Sammy Saul's
on the sound effects.
All right, Brach's announced
it's newest seasonal treat.
Turkey dinner candy corn.
Brach's has given us
the Thanksgiving dinner
no one really asked for.
In every bag, there's flavors like,
cranberry sauce, green
bean stuffing, (mumbles).
My favorite, can't get enough of it.
And roast Turkey, okay?
So I've got my tiny, little
Thanksgiving right here.
VFS, who's ready to feast with me, Jason?
- [Jason] Hi Drew.
- Hi Jason!
- Hello.
- You ready to try this?
- I'm doing it, I've got my bag.
I think I have a Turkey, here it goes.
- What color are you doing?
All right, down the hatch.
- It's the yellow top, brown bottom.
Yeah, that's turkey.
- I think I got like pumpkin pie,
'cause mine's really sweet
and it's actually really good.
- Well, I'm not saying this
is bad, but definitely meaty.
(audience laughing)
- Jason, I couldn't wanna be doing this
with anybody else more,
you are so awesome.
Thank you so much for diving into this.
Surprisingly, mine was
delicious, so Brach's, call me.
Thanks Jason, all right, it's no secret,
I am an animal lover.
That's why this next story caught my eye.
It's been said that when
your cat stares at you
really intensely and then slowly blinks,
it's giving you a cat kiss.
Pop sugar has consulted
with vets who say it's true.
When a cat stares at
you, it's often because
she's trying to connect
and show affection.
So if she blinks, blink right back.
Still got some pumpkin pie right here.
Look, these are my cats, Peach and Lucky.
Oh, they're loving me so hard right now.
Lucky's even giving me the one-eyed wink.
And by the way, the
reason I love this story
is because I have a lot of animals, okay?
I have a yellow parrot, a bearded dragon,
two dogs, I have chickens!
And I have to say
something in all sincerity,
they do wink at you.
And they do not have the power of voice.
And I do think it's how they're saying,
like they're happy, they're
content, they're throwing you,
you know, the bone of gratitude
and just saying, I love you
so, right back at you guys.
(audience clapping)
Okay, time for a beauty junkie alert!
(audience cheers)
All right, these products
that have just hit the shelves
are good for the environment
and your daily beauty routine.
Pumpkin pie, Marie
Claire (chokes), Brach's.
Marie Claire has a list
of a solid, oh no sorry,
these are bar shampoos and conditioners.
And they can replace all
of those plastic bottles.
I definitely, I'm very
excited to speak about
all the alternatives, paper and aluminum
and you know, just glass,
different resources.
But these have eradicated all of it
and it's so much better
for the environment.
So check it out, lather,
rinse, save the planet, repeat.
(upbeat music)
♪ Whoa whoa ♪